The joe rogan experience.
Yeah. Thanks the belt on.
How are you fuckers doing great man.
It's great to be on the show again.
Great to have you guys here. Um, you know,
I was watching your Instagram the other
day and I was looking at you with fake
hips doing crazy fucking heavy
dead lifts. Man, that's amazing.
I am starting to dead lift a little
bit more because I've been doing this
carnivore diet and I feel great and
there's no reason not to, right? So, um,
I just figured if I can do it and it
doesn't hurt, Diana, why not? So, uh,
I was going up til about 400 pounds,
but I think I can still,
I think I can even get stronger now.
So what I am so happy about is this is
something squatting and deadlifting.
It's something that was part
of my life all growing up.
I was a power lifter all growing up and
he's the one that got me into this shit
and it, it got taken away from me and
I was really sad and disappointed.
Became a drug addict and an alcoholic
because of it. And now I can lift again.
So I feel good that is that unusual for
someone who's got artificial hips to be
able to do something like
that? Um, do you know,
do how many people don't know
that have artificial hips? Well,
I do know that Ed Cohen, who's the
greatest power lifter of all time,
he has two fake hips now,
right? Yeah, I think so.
I think he's still squat 600 gs.
Eddie Cohen, check him out. He's a
beast. Fake hips squatting 600 pounds.
They sees days like one of
the most effective replacement
surgeries that they do
is replacing apples.
I think it's a great and a big deal.
I think it's a great surgery.
Before I got it done, I mean,
I couldn't even get up out of a chair.
I was, I'd be stuck, you know, I would,
I would stick places and um, before I got
it done, I couldn't really move at all.
And then after I got it done,
they had botched one side.
So one side went perfect.
The other side for two years was all
screwed up and the doctors didn't know it.
What was screwed up about
it. Um, the, the cup,
there's a cup and then there's
the ball that goes into the cup.
The Cup came loose and it would,
it would shift around.
Now they think the cup comes loose
because when you do both hips at the same
time,
they hammer one hip and the one side and
then you're completely like a dead body
almost. And they flip you over.
It's really an island actually.
When they flip you over,
they think that's when the hit might,
that socket may come out.
So, um, they're starting to,
to question doing them both
on the same day. Now, yeah,
I've heard of people getting one done.
Then a couple months later
I would recommend getting
one done because then when
I got my other one,
when I got the one that was messed up
redone and I had one good leg and one know
one leg to recover on,
it was so much easier.
I didn't have to have the special toilet
and how the other students are going to
be on crutches instead of being
in a wheelchair probably right.
If you only had one bag.
So I actually wasn't even on crutches.
I came home from the hospital and that
day that I came home from the hospital I
was,
I was walking,
I even climbed a ladder and our mom
yelled at us and yelled at me because I
climbed a ladder and she's like, what
are you doing? He just got a hip surgery.
I got to change this light bulb.
I would think that one good benefit
about weightlifting would be increase in
bone density as you want that to have
artificial hips especially cause you got
that bar that goes down deep into the
bone and the hip got a Dexa scan done.
Weird shit going on.
We've got really weird shit going on.
We had a Dexa scan done and Dr.
Jacob Wilson told us that our bone,
was it bone mineral density.
Density density. Yeah, it was mine.
Mine was like off the charts,
but his was way off the charts.
We also got a biopsy done by Dr
Andy Galpin and he's just like,
dude, he's like, I don't the
fuck's going on with your,
with my muscle and his muscle. He's like,
but we need to talk about this morning.
So it's called steroids. I know. Yeah.
So he said he wanted to interview me more
in and talk to me more about like what
I've taken over the years ago.
It was different. Things works.
It works fantastic when people do it.
I just think,
I heard you talking the other day about
throwing a roundhouse kick and he said
it's a second nature to you. And I think
for us, we've been lifting for so long,
a lot of this stuff,
even when I was a drug addict and
alcoholic the entire time I still try and
every day I wasn't doing as good of a job,
but I still would make it to the
gym everyday. It's ingrained in us.
It's something that
we've been doing forever.
So I think that is just designed for it.
It's essentially designed for,
not designed,
but you've sort of designed it.
And I think it's something
that found us, you know, like,
like we did kind of stumble upon it.
But I think it's something that
found us and it's uh, you know,
I was strong right out of the gate. He
was strong right out of the gate. I mean,
I remember, uh, my friend's bench in the
garage and they were benching the bar,
maybe a 10 on each side and I was,
you know, doing a plate, doing one 85,
12 years old, you know, he was
an animal when he was young.
It was just something there, there
was some sort of strength. My mom,
our mom benched, uh,
what she meant 35. Yeah,
she's been mom can bench one
35 like right off, you know,
like without ever lifting. I want
to say, I think she benched one 85.
She might've been the same day cause Joey
ideas would say immigrant mentality as
a mother from where's she from?
She's a Polish right. You Go,
I just got something in my heart
thought I'm just, I'm just white
mix 23 and me done. I got one of
those things done and I, yeah,
I'm like Irish and a tea. I'm like only
4% Italian. I thought we were more,
but it makes no sense. Our grandmother
was directly from Sicily, so I don't,
I don't understand how that happened.
Yeah. We don't know what's going on. Yeah.
Well, even if she's
from Sicily, who knows?
Like how it happened and she was
over there where she came from.